a wartime leader acknowledging and
reflecting on the most horrific end to a
war ever known Vladimir zielinski
alongside Japanese prime minister fumio
kishida at the Hiroshima Peace Memorial
a reminder of how two U.S atomic bombs
killed at least 100
000 people in Hiroshima and Nagasaki 78
years ago
zielinski said the old images of
destroyed Hiroshima reminded him of the
city of bakmut Ukraine as it looks today
on Sunday Russian TV showed the Goddard
remains of bakmut along with a statement
of congratulations from Vladimir Putin
the Kremlin now says Bak moot has been
fully captured from Ukraine after a
nine-month battle led by the Russian
mercenary Wagner group
in a second such message of the weekend
the head of Wagner yevgeni pragosian
said there are no Ukrainian soldiers in
bakmut because we have stopped taking
prisoners it has been captured down to
the last centimeter back in Hiroshima
zielinski initially appeared to confirm
the news
in Ukraine's hands
the Russians say they take you backward
I think no
but you have to to understand that there
is nothing they destroyed everything but
with Ukrainian forces claiming they
still had a foothold zelenski later
clarified saying the battle is not over
we are in Baku today where exactly I'm
not going to tell you but this means
that bakmut has not been conquered by
Russia at this point it may be semantics
or just a matter of time before Russia
holds 100 control of bakmut zelenski
said that his soldiers who remain are
fulfilling an important task likely
referring to their continuation of a
long battle that has drained Russian
resources
that ahead of the anticipated Ukrainian
counter-offensive something zelenski
says Russia will feel when it happens
much of the land Ukraine aims to retake
is now little more than just that land
Redmond Shannon Global News London